on a fait un petit résumé de ce qu'on a
appelé l'affairé garrido et je vais vous
dire ici nous on est pour que tout le
monde ce qui est un jeu vous dire donc
invendable je pense qu'on va se faire
des petits bisous c'est vrai que magnéto
quoi danseur né pour que tout le monde
se griffe mais excuse moi vous êtes dans
la merde on vient vous êtes encore sur
les grosses têtes au delà il faut et
votre émission le gard la sphère garrido
ses parcs la feria rideau raquel garrido
avocat de profession impliqué dans la
vie politique décide de changer de voie
pour faire carrière à la télévision mais
son arrivée dans le paf va créer de
nombreuses polémiques 4 octobre 2010
cette suite à l'incident tragique qui a
eu lieu au stade damien raquel poste un
tweet
j'ai assisté ce soir au match psg
bordeaux événement qui coûtent des
millions tandis qu'amiens une tribune
s'effondre cherchez l'erreur
ce message a provoqué la colère d'un
certain pierre ménès qui dès le
lendemain va lui répondre sur le plateau
de touche pas à mon poste cuse et moir
espèce de tour tu vois quand même en
effet le journaliste va la traiter de
tourtes gilles verdez il ramène sur le
plateau des terriens du dimanche pour
apporter à laquelle une tourte
c'est ici que tout va basculer une
question terrible sera même posé sur le
plateau de touche pas à mon poste
est-ce qu'il faut la virer oui vous des
tice et oui vous dites non ici
aujourd'hui bien d'autres questions se
posent
raquel fait-elle tout ça pour le buzz
quelles sont ses véritables convictions
et surtout quel est le temps de cuisson
d'une tourte toutes ces questions
auxquelles va répondre
l'inspecteur baba voir là dedans c'est
qu'en fait il n'y a eu que des conneries
en fait on fait on sait même pas pour
cité moncel même pas prompt s'est
embrouillé en fait avec l'équipe de foot
à l'heure annoncée bras voilà qui on
veut attaquer ni si franchement que sur
certaines interventions je les aime
beaucoup mais vous avez dépassé les
banques moi j'avais dit que vous deviez
partir
j'attends toujours je pensais que vous
aviez été trop loin voilà je vous dis
sincèrement moi je pense qu'elle doit
elle doit rayer elle va rester sur 8
parce que franchement la presse ap la
rixe est long dans l'émission de thierry
mais franchement vous le mettez vous
auriez dû faire de la télé depuis bien
longtemps
eh bien écoutez sait jamais trop tard
c'est vrai que vous allez c'est vrai
vous êtes notamment une émission sur ces
8 ou pas c'est ce qu'on m'a dit ah bon
vous a dit ça ouais je sais pas je crois
que vous êtes mieux placé que moi non
pas du tout dans les hauts-de-seine
je ne connais pas la direction non mais
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit c'est la rumeur
non mais c'est bon ou pas je me méfie
des rumeurs que vous lancez à propos de
ma carrière sur ces 8 parce que la
dernière fois vous avez dit que j'allais
peut-être virer donc s'est avéré faux tu
vois j'ai l'impression l'embrouillé
n'est pas fini raquel en tout cas bon
vous êtes complet mais là je me plais dû
me régale avec avec l'aps à tous mes
camarades chez thierry ardisson je me
régale seul intérêt à dire 4 et galettes
avec moi du cachet à côté vous en faites
jeremstar aussi ah oui très sympa que ça
oui ah oui j'ai j'ai découvert ce jeune
homme et ses seins c'est un copain
combat il a hélas pas mon âge les plus
jeunes mais c'est vraiment mon bep ch'ti
quoi et excellence alors la politique au
sens partisan est au centre du mouvement
ça c'est fini
mais voilà j'ai pris un engagement
auprès du csa et je vais pas jouer à la
maline en disant j'ai dit sa part de vos
poissons et les maracas et ça ça m'a
coûté 3
aujourd'hui en faction à la rabine
éclater cette gare de l'humain
absolument le gaf avec son offre et
loyal voilà on m'a très bien vous êtes
content de voir à quel ou pas
franchement ça tournait très content et
dynamique parce qu'elle est déjà venu
mais voilà mes raquettes c'est la
première fois qu'elle soit en tout cas
chirac m qu'est ce qu'un basara je veux
dire à quoi tient à temps madame
dépendant du nom je trouve ça courageux
de venir sur le plateau effectivement ça
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai